Speaker 1: Well, if you thought the hate mob
yesterday was going to stop with donald Trump
Jr and candace Owens, that's bad enough, by
the way. It didn't last night. Sean hannity,
fox news propagandist, took a break from
interviewing donald trump in order to
direct the hate mob against me. And it led
to yet another round of insane threats and
anti-Semitism. Anti-Semitism, which, by the way,
The Daily Wire's Michael Knowles says, I made up,
which in 5 minutes I will show you is sadly very
much not made up. But let's not start with that
right now. Sean HANNITY jumping on the bandwagon
and attacking me. But interestingly, he doesn't
even actually quote me or show my tweet. He
quotes someone talking about my tweet. What kind
of production value is this? How pathetic. They
couldn't even be bothered. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Didn't stop there. One
awful progressive talk show host,
quote, joking about the victims, not praying
enough. That's supposed to be funny. I thought
attacking one's personal religious beliefs was
not allowed in the leftist woke world we live in.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So up on the screen is a quote
by someone named Kendall Tits or she's Kendall
tweets. I have to admit, I don't actually know how
it's how it's pronounced. And it says it's a quote
from Kendall, progressive talk show host David
Pakman mocked the Covenant School community for
not praying enough. Of course, that's not what I
did. I pointed out that prayers don't work to stop
mass shootings. HANNITY Can't even be bothered to
show the tweet. He just goes, I don't know. I'll
quote Kendall tweets or Kendall tits. What the
hell is wrong with these people? And of course,
another wave of anti-Semitism always focused on
me being Jewish. And by the way, by the way, by
the way, I'm going to talk about the anti-Semitism
stuff in a moment. But, you know, I received a lot
of messages of support overnight. And I'm going
to talk about some of those a little bit later.
Unless you are on the receiving end of
the sort of barrage that these right
wing people do. It is every platform.
It's a thousand posts on Instagram,
it's a thousand emails, it's a hundred
thousand tweets directed at you. One second.
You step away for a half hour and look. And then
there's thousands more. Just endless. Endless.
These. Borderline riotous mobs that are in the
audience of folks like Sean HANNITY. So there
it is. HANNITY Jumping in on the action, creating
another barrage. And now what I want to get to.
Oh, and by the way, so many people signing up at
join Pacman dot com with the coupon code. Cancel
cancel these people like HANNITY and others they
claim to be against canceling. And yet now for
48 hours they've been running campaigns to try to
get me canceled by writing to my advertisers the
number of people I am flattered and I will
delve into this later. Who did go to join
Pacman dot com after I mentioned it yesterday and
signed up using the coupon code. Cancel. Cancel
like cancel the counselors. Stunning numbers and
we're going to get to that a little bit later.